ドンドンッボンっボ、ボンっ
うぁ～！！あっあっ
バンバンバｎうわっ！バンバンバン
うぅぇ！
みなさんバランスボールはご存知でしょうか
体のバランスを鍛える、体幹を鍛える、
ボールのことでございます
で今回はこのボールをたくさん準備して
あるんですけども
僕、あることがしたくて
バランスボールを買いました
バランスボールで何をしたいかと言いますと、
こういうバランスをとるのは
よくあるんですけども
転がるとスーッといくんすよ
一回やってみましょう
う”わーど！
う”わー！
要するにこうっすよ
こういくと滑れるんですよこうやって
こういう感じでね！
二つでやるとこうなります
うお！スゲ！スゲ
今の感じみたいにバランスボールにこう、
乗ってツーっといくと
ボールの転がりを利用して
ローリング機能を使ってこのまま
スーっていけるんすよ
今二つであれだけ移動できたんで
もしこれを
大量のバランスボールでやったら
一回のスライディングで7.5メートル
約8メートル分ぐらい
スライディングできるんじゃねーかと思ったので
ちょっと一回バランスボールで今回それを実験してみたいと思います。
では行こう!!!
その時、
私はまだ知らなかった
このあとに起こる
悲劇を・・
そうっすね
僕は
できると思ってました
できるかできないか分からない
そういうことを、ひとつずつ
クリアしていきたいっすね
あのもう一番奥までいったらクリアです
一回のスライディングで
７メートルスライディングしたことになるので
勢いがポイントかな
あと死なないことを祈ってやってみましょう
では行こう！
いきます！
（ボンッ！)
あきらめたら（はっ）
（まって）終了じゃないすか
その先にある輝きを
見たいっすね
（助走が足りないんだよ、もっと？）
スピード重視でいきましょう
（ボンッ）
（グシグ！）
常に次のバランスボールに
体をこうおいて
♪（陽気な音楽）
こういう感じで
んで、もう一個にぶつかっちゃうから
それを防ぐために
２個目になる前にもう
こうやって　♪（陽気な音楽）
ちゃんちゃんちゃんちゃか…♪
こうね
次はちょとこれでやってみましょう
いきます
（ボン！ボン！ボン！ボン！ボン！）
ぷわあ”－！
分からないからこそ
できるかどうか
そういうのを
やっていきたいですね
やっぱ上だね
たぶん滑るのは難しいと思うんで
やっぱりたぶん上が一番僕は
いいと思いました
ちょと上を狙っていきましょう
走ってみます上を
そうっすねぇ
youtubeの
星になりたいなぁ
（ボンッ！）
（グキッ！）
あぁ～ヤバいヤバいヤバい
あぁ
やらかしちゃったｗ
♪～ED(負傷ver.)～♪
たぶんちょっと間を空ければ
滑れるから
一回これでやってみましょう
２列だとたぶん安定感があるので
これならいけると思います
いきます
こうね
ぼんっぼふ
やったー！
イターイ！
まって
頭蓋骨ハソン、頭蓋骨ハソン